hey everyone welcome to another tech
related video and in this one i'll be
going over exactly not my predictions
but what we actually want from the next
version of the iphone software the
iphone third generation software so
we're all familiar with the first
generation iphone the second generation
iphone was iphone 3g and the third
generation iphone software is coming out
i don't know about anything hardware
wise but i definitely know what i would
like in terms of software so i'm just
going to be going over a number of these
things with you guys today
the first thing that i would like is
obviously cut and paste has been a big
thing missing from the previous
generation iphone um if i were to bring
out my lg voyager right now i could copy
and paste from a notepad document and
send it as a text as a text message or i
could copy and paste from a website and
send the url to someone via text message
so that's just one of the things that
the iphone
uh software has really been lacking and
that could have been like the next big
thing for the iphone uh the cut and
paste feature so that's the first thing
the second thing is that the iphone um
the current software cannot forward a
text message um or cannot send or
receive sms messages or mms messages
which is picture messages or video
messages
i hate to bring it up over and over
again but i have a very basic media
phone the lg voyager and
forwarding message is very easy but how
many how often do you actually get a
message um saying like with a message
that you want to forward to someone else
you can't do that you can forward emails
just fine which is great but that
text message forwarding feature is
non-existent in the current iphone
software and the other thing is mms
messaging you can't send or receive
pixel messages obviously the email
client is very good you can send and
receive pictures and email but um the
you can't do
you can't do picture messaging via text
message on the iphone software anyway i
still haven't told you guys what my two
current phones are so the first one i'll
show you is the lg voyager that's the
the newest phone that i have i've been a
verizon person my whole life so i'm not
my whole life but the latest two phones
that i have are from verizon and the
next one is this this little flip phone
here my first actual flip on i thought
it was the coolest thing in the world
but um
so this is the my older phone and you
can see on the front it's a verizon
phone okay
and the lg voyager is obviously verizon
so i'll be comparing a lot of features
like um having an actual hard camera
button so that i can take pictures like
just stuff like that i'm comparing what
i've had in my experience with other
cell phones to what i would like in the
newest version of the iphone software
what about sending
sending appointments to contacts that's
another useful feature that should be
included i think by default on a lot of
business phones
and again the iphone 3g it's very good
phone but the ability to send a calendar
appointment to a contact which i do have
on this phone here um it's a really nice
feature actually if you want to tell
someone like um where and when are we
meeting or something you can just like
pull it up in your calendar shoot off to
him and put the phone down and you're
done instead of telling him it'll be at
this place at this time and you have of
course the up and down keyboard so it's
not going to be the fastest in the world
but i i understand the current version
of the software but i'm just thinking of
things i would like to see and then the
new version of iphone software so we'll
see what they release we'll see what
comes out and i'll i'll keep looking
into this kind of stuff oh yeah there's
no weekly calendar view for some reason
there's daily there's
monthly could we have the ability to
save an email as a draft i know we can
do that on a lot of cell phones now i
have never texted with an iphone but i
can on my current phones i can save a
text message as a draft and i can save
an email as a draft
in the iphone client there is no such
thing you cannot save an email as a
draft and come back to it later and i
understand it's a it's a business phone
as well as a messaging phone as well
because you can have applications and
games on it but why not be able to save
an email as a draft that would just be
nice i know they introduced the new mass
deleting feature in the new version of
the iphone software but that that would
be pretty cool i would like that and
last but not at all least
flash support on the iphone
what everyone wants their iphone 3g to
support flash okay
um it's been a big thing everyone's like
why doesn't the iphone have flash oh i
mean not a lot of phones do have flash
but just the fact that it's such a great
phone great graphics great screen
resolution okay great web browsing
everyone would be like well if it had
flash it would be just awesome okay
flash support would allow you to stream
music on from a website play games
online and i mean the app store kind of
solves a lot of that criteria but it's
paid so if we can have a just a really
great built-in flash support on the new
version of the iphone software i'll wrap
up this video because it's probably
getting kind of long um but yeah that's
what i would like um out of the new
iphone software
um i can't expect much from verizon to
acquire the iphone i mean at t and
iphone and apple are just still rolling
solid but
again if apple were to put the iphone on
more than one network they would
definitely get a lot more money out of
it because not everyone on verizon is
begging to get their lg dare right now
no they don't know i wouldn't mind
having an iphone on verizon so anyway
that is what i'd like out of the newest
version of the iphone software coming
out tuesday march 17th stay tuned for it
go to apple.com continually check your
mac rumors your apple.com for updates
and that is basically it so um
thanks for watching this one and i
apologize about the quality again
because i'm using a webcam here but if
you do have a suggestion for a camera i
should buy i'm looking for hd cam
recorder
send me a message subscribe and also i
do lots of tutorials so just subscribe
and send me a message and i'll do
whatever tutorial you guys come up with
so thanks for watching this one enjoy
peace